so republicans in congress
congress people in general are often
shielded from
the rules that they put in place for
others
oftentimes
congress people
will skirt the law
sometimes they will act brazenly
as is the case with matt gates
and i have covered him on my channel for
a while now this case that's rolling
through this investigation that's
happening the justice department looking
into his untoward immoral behavior with
children
which is an interesting thing since he's
touring the country with the q anon
princess
marjorie taylor green
and save the children is their their
motto
well matt gates his associate joel
greenberg
is now actually
cooperating with the government and it's
not
looking good for lil maddy gates
abc says gates associate providing fed's
intel documents as probe into
congressman continues sources former tax
collector joel greenberg is cooperating
with investigators
none of this is good news for matt gates
they were thick as thieves these two
sending venmo payments to underage girls
with with notes like books for school
to add insult to injury
as the federal investigation into
florida rep matt gates continues into
the summer sources tell abc news that
gates's one-time wingman
has been steadily providing information
and handing over potential evidence that
could implicate the florida congressman
and others and others
and others
in the sprawling probe
former seminole county tax collector
joel greenberg as part of his ongoing
cooperation with prosecutors has
provided investigators with years
of venmo and cash app transactions and
thousands of photos and videos as well
as access to personal social media
accounts sources said
again
not good
not good on its face that matt gates is
a creeper
a sickening vile alleged pedophile
but also that
this this man is a leader of the
republican party
a stalwart
example for young republicans everywhere
and this is what we got
private messages exclusively reviewed by
abc news potentially shed new light on
the process by which greenberg allegedly
met women online who were paid for sex
and introduce them to the florida
congressman and other
associates
this investigation isn't just going to
end here
there will likely be other powerful
people within the infrastructure of
florida leadership who are implicated in
this
gringberg pleaded guilty in may to
multiple federal crimes including sex
trafficking of a minor and introducing
her to other quote unquote adult men
who also had sex with her when she was
under age
greenberg agreed to provide quote
substantial assistance unquote to
prosecutors as part of their ongoing
investigation
matt gates should be quaking in his
boots
instead
he's touring the country on his maga
parade
trying to to whip up crowds into a
frenzy and maybe incite another
insurrection the first of which he was
so fond